millions of people in New York City
means billions of events every day join
us as we talk with New York City Cyber
Command about what these events are why
it's important to track them and how
they build a scalable system to protect
all the people in New York City on this
episode of snapchat thanks for joining
us today know can you tell us a little
bit about what New York City cyber
command does sure thanks for having us
so New York City cyber command is an
organization that is responsible
preventing detecting responding and
recovering to any threats to our city
systems that's a pretty big mandate and
you've got a lot of information coming
in every day can you tell me how you
built a pipeline to process all that
data we have tons of log sources I think
we're approaching 20 now and we'll have
more by the day so we have on cloud and
on-prem and the way we split things up
is that for on-prem log sources we use
the syslog-ng protocol and we use it to
enrich all logs with metadata whether it
be IPS or timestamps and so on for on
cloud these Google's cloud functions to
perform a similar function so once we
get that data we can output it using
Google's pops up and we have an
application called flow control that
inputs all this data and it runs on
Google's data flow and Apache beam in
order to remove all corrupt meaningless
or incomplete data so further down the
pipeline we don't have to handle it and
we don't have to distract from the
parsers so once that's complete we once
again use Google's pops up to now take
all our logs into our main piece of
logic which is the parsers so for every
single log we have a different set of
code whether it's separated by a bunch
of mumbo-jumbo or comma-separated and so
on now we can make it into meaningful
data and something that's queryable by
our security analysts and the best place
for that would be bigquery once it's in
bigquery we can start taking our data
playing machine learning algorithms
outputting it into dashboards or just
having something as simple as having our
security analysts query it and find
something dangerous or maybe a hacking
attempt so if you could go back and tell
past known what what to do from the
beginning what what lesson would you
give yourself to make this whole process
easier Google pub/sub is on order and as
a result that made it so that we had to
add a lot of additional complex logic
later on in order to reassemble some of
our data our log sources are split up
and sometimes a message might come in
now and then the remainder of that
message might come 20 minutes later a
couple hours later or tomorrow and when
messages are ordered we don't really
know when something is necessarily tied
into another message tell me a little
bit about what's coming next what new
evolutions you excited about for this
pipeline right so we have three
approaches so firstly we want to expand
on their machine learning algorithms we
have a supervised and unsupervised
application that is essentially an alpha
right now we want to finish it and we
want to have it outputting meaningful
results then we want to start spreading
our pipeline to other cities we want to
maybe write some white papers or some
research topics and have them create a
similar secure space that we have and
finally we want to expand the same space
right now we're creating a simulation
environment that is nearly identical to
our own and we can use that to gather
training data and model some of the
attacks that are coming against city
systems it's great to know that you and
your team are working hard to keep us
all safe thank you very much thank you
interested in checking out Apache beam
and data flow get started with some
templates to get up and running quickly
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content we'll see you on the
next episode of stack chat
[Music]
you